what's popping X-Men it's me Mt and this
is a breakdown of the first X-Men film
from the year 2000 and thank God why 2K
didn't happen because this movie is an
absolute classic that really puts
superheroes on the map as more than just
super powered Goody Two-Shoes and
spandex but cemented superhero movies as
a legitimate medium to address real
world issues so let's dive into this
movie and a little bit as to how it was
made together my nerd babies this movie
wastes no time letting the audience know
what kind of superhero movie it is
because as the 20th century logo Fades
away we can see that the X and the word
Fox lingers in the darkness I have an X
that lingers in the darkness she won't
let me sleep
which is a fantastic way to start the
world's first X-Men film then after we
travel through an animated sequence of
what appears to be
to be workings of mutant DNA the movie
starts us off by showing us the tragic
mutant origins of the movie's antagonist
Eric lencher whose mutant powers
manifested in direct response to the
traumatic events of the Holocaust and
while this is very much a somber way to
start off a superhero film starting the
entire X-Men franchise off with Eric's
time during the Holocaust not only
allowed the audience to sympathize with
Magneto's motivations right off the bat
but also serve to let the audience at
the time know that they weren't going to
watch yet another super cheesy and
unbelievable superhero film but one
rooted deeply in actual reality that
serves as a meaningful message about the
nature of humanity and why what makes us
different actually makes us more
beautiful and shouldn't be feared with
the X-Men Comics having been
specifically made to highlight the
struggles of an oppressed group of
people starting off with one of the
worst real-life examples of
discriminatory persecution of all time
was a powerful way for viewers to
instantly connect with this new but
familiar universe as we get a shot of
the captives walking through the mud the
contrast this movie makes by having the
captives gold star brands on their
clothes stand out against the otherwise
gray and dreary scene is a super
profound way of painting the picture of
why Magneto cannot stand the darkness of
a world that feels the need to label
human beings as other sir Ian McKellen
was actually one of the first people The
Producers cast for this film and one of
mcallen's biggest reasons for even doing
this particular comic book movie was
because he was drawn to this movie's
realistic and human script centered
solely around topics of discrimination
something that he could personally
relate to in his own way being a gay man
all his life but anyways as Magneto uses
his powers for the first time on the
gate you can see that he is also using
his powers to keep four whole Nazi
from taking him down it is
literally only when he is knocked
unconscious that the men are able to
bring Eric to the ground which is kind
of super impressive for his first time
then we fast forward to the modern day
to rogue's Hometown in Meridian
Mississippi which is the same state that
Rogue actually comes from in the comics
although comic book Rogue hails from the
fictional called the Cod County instead
as Anna paquin's Rogue talks to her
boyfriend we can see imagery on the wall
foreshadowing the future events of the
movie the postcard of New York City with
a cutout of the Statue of Liberty points
to the end of the movie where Rogue is
strapped to Magneto's machine at the
Statue of Liberty on Ellis Island a
postcard of Washington DC points to both
Jean Gray and Senator Kelly's speeches
at the Capitol building and above a
postcard of Niagara Falls we can see
another Canadian postcard of the CN
Tower in Toronto both postcards
foreshadowing rogue's runaway journey to
Canada after kissing her boyfriend David
into a coma but speaking of David in the
comics the name of the boy Rogue nearly
kisses to death isn't David but actually
Cody Robbins but the X-Men production
reportedly changed the name to David as
a shout out to David Haider one of the
main writers of the movie and yes I am
talking about the very same David Haider
who is famously known for being the
iconic voice of solid snake in the metal
gear franchise and even shows up later
in the film as a museum cop but speaking
of the Capitol building the next scene
switches to Washington DC and a very
unique looking Senate hearing room that
looks nothing like it does in real life
during this hearing concerning the
dangers of mutant kind Bruce Davidson
Senator Kelly whips out a list of known
mutants and mentions a girl in Illinois
who can walk through walls clearly
referring to the wall-defying mutant
Kitty Pride who is mostly a background
character played by actress sumila K
that we can see attending both Professor
Xavier and Storm's classes later on in
the film but speaking of Senator Kelly's
list of identified mutants we also get
our first potential appearance of
Mystique in this film technically as we
can see the form of Henry guyrich
handing Kelly that list during Gene's
speech Magneto does tell Kelly that guy
Rich has been dead for quite some time
later on so there's a chance that the
real Henry guyrich was never in this
movie at all but as Senator Kelly ends
his xenophobic speech to a standing
ovation you can see that his head is
perfectly framed Against The Shining
golden image of the Capitol building in
the background likely a decision by the
director to make him look like the shy
finding Holy Savior figure for America
that Senator Kelly believes himself to
be and also when Xavier confronts Eric
in the hallway of the Capitol building I
love the subtle big white x-shaped beams
in the background as they talk about the
future of mutant kind a very clever way
to visually represent the tense
atmosphere of this scene in an X-Men
film also the use of Shadow to cover
Eric's face until he actually turns to
face Xavier was a baller choice because
right off the bat it shows that Magneto
is the type of villain who plots in the
shadows only revealing himself when he
chooses and according to movie producer
Ralph winter they intentionally focused
on molding Professor X after Martin
Luther King and Magneto after Malcolm X
which I thought was a fantastic choice
to really sell this superhero world as a
relatable one as those two real-life
Warriors against discrimination had two
very different ways of seeking change
but anyways we then meet up again with
Rogue in Northern Alberta Canada after
getting a ride from a truck driver
played by George booza who also played
the X-Men beast in the 90s X-Men
animated series Busa drives a liberty
truck which is yet another piece of
foreshadowing towards rogue's eventual
trip to the Statue of Liberty as well as
just a shout out to the concept of
Liberty in general and a movie about
discrimination his character can also be
seen sleeping behind a toy truck while
Wolverine and Rogue sit at the bar
Alberta Canada is also where Logan
originally grew up as a boy in the
comics which is likely why Alberta was
chosen as the first appearance of
Wolverine in this movie also here's a
crazy fact as iconic as Hugh Jackman has
been in the role of Wolverine ever since
this movie he wasn't actually the first
choice Russell Crowe was actually
approached first but turned the role
down due to him feeling like he didn't
want to play a wolf man leading to actor
Doug Ray Scott being initially cast in
the role however because Scott was also
tied up with filming Mission Impossible
2 as that movie's main villain Doug Gray
was forced to drop out as Wolverine
leading to Jackman getting a surprise
callback nine months after he initially
auditioned for the role but anyways when
Logan approaches the bar we can see that
he's wearing the same jacket that we see
in get from that old couple that got
assassinated in Logan's origin story
painfully detailed in X-Men Origins
Wolverine shout out to the spoiler man
Paul for that one because he's a smart
British man but anyways moving on as
Rogue hitches a ride with Logan she
notices his Canadian style dog tags that
he got shortly before he had his
adamantium skeleton installed at William
Striker's secret military base at Alkali
Lake then after Wolverine learns a hard
lesson about seat belt safety we are
introduced to the X-Men universe's first
iteration of Sabretooth played by actor
Tyler Mayne a dude built like a wrestler
well mostly because he actually used to
be one before the shooting of this movie
dude was a whole WCW wrestler the role
of sabertooth was actually initially
offered to wrestler Kevin Nash but pay
disputes caused Nash to turn the roll
down then after Sabretooth knocks
Wolverine out after absolutely launching
the man with a tree we can see that
Wolverine's claws naturally retract when
he's unconscious implying that Wolverine
has to be awake to consciously Flex his
outwards there seems to be a degree of
mental focus with Wolverine's Powers
then as Halle Berry storm and James
Marsden Cyclops go to save Rogue we can
see that Cyclops purposely reduce the
strength of his i-beams in order to not
send Rogue to Heaven by accident would
Rogue go to heaven I don't know she'd
put that boy in a coma
we can see Cyclops use a special dial on
the side of his visor to regulate his
powers later on in the movie when he
uses his powers to remove Toad's
surprise slime from his girlfriend's
face in the comics toad saliva is
actually incredibly acidic to the point
of being able to melt most things so
let's just say Gene is lucky her face
card did not get declined in X2 and X3
she's still hot still very hot to this
day Jesus Christ Famke Jensen anyway
sorry oh but speaking of toad after
Cyclops manages to impressively drag
Logan's extremely heavy adamantium body
away from his exploding mobile home we
get our first look at Mortimer toynbie
as the mutant toad as played by the
agile actor Ray Park an actor that I was
absolutely surprised to see can still
move around so well after holding the
entire phantom menace movie on his back
as the villainous Darth Maul Ray Park
even shows off some of his Darth Maul
skills a little bit when he picks up a
metal object later on in the film The
Producers of this movie completely
reinvented Toad's design and personality
from being this jester-like suck up to
Magneto to being an actual formidable
badass Rey Park's depiction of toad was
so badass in fact that it drastically
changed the look and character direction
of toad in the comics to make him as
cool and dangerous as he was in the
movie Once Marvel Comics saw Ray Park's
toad completely flat in a museum guard
to death they knew that they had to
update comic book toad to keep up but
also fun fact about that squashed Museum
damn cop he was actually played by Tom
DeSanto one of the movies executive
producers and head writers in the comics
toad is very Adept at machines so having
toad be one of the key designers for
Magneto's mutated machine makes a lot of
sense but anyways after Sabertooth
growls at toad with the vocal cords of
an actual tiger he enters Magneto's main
office where Magneto has got a Newton's
Cradle on his desk going on and on
without any strings whatsoever I thought
this was a clever way to show the
audience the extent of Magneto's Mastery
over metal because he is able to carry
on a full conversation and fully walk
out of the room before his Newton's
Cradle fell apart we then get our first
look at the Subterranean secret HQ of
the X-Men as Gene attempts to put an IV
into an unconscious Logan fun facts
about the X-Men's basement hallway to
cerebro all the walls of the set are
actually floating as they're all
attached to the ceiling of the
Production Studio with the cerebral room
itself being located on a completely
different set they did this so that they
could make lighting for this scene a lot
easier but anyways even though X2 had
yet to come out I love how they sort of
teased Wolverine's Trauma from his past
experimentations when he immediately
enters fight or flight mode the second
he realized he's about to be poked and
prodded like some part of his fractured
memory seems to push into major defense
mode here and as Logan starts to run
into the X hallway he runs into the
X-Men's uniforms being housed in glass
cases much like Batman tends to house
the costumes of the bat family in his
underground hideout even though the
producers didn't want to undermine the
realistic aspect of their Universe with
the X-Men running around in yellow
spandex they still wanted to give the
group a uniform to keep the spirit of
the original X-Men Comics alive as that
original X-Men Comics team would all
make sure to color coordinate before
they headed out well everybody except
Iceman who famously preferred to fight
in the nude I'm just kidding he was a
nude but was he I think he was yeah it
was kind of nude but if Mystique can
fight nude then soak and Bob it but if
you look closely there appears to be
three men's uniforms in three women's
uniforms despite this movie only having
four active of X-Men with Cyclops storm
Gene gray and eventually Logan with the
other two likely being given to both
Rogue and Iceman after the end of this
film though the original comic book
lineup of X-Men consisted of Cyclops
Jean Ray Beast Angel and Iceman Stan Lee
said that the producers of the movie
opted to bench Beast Angel and Iceman in
favor of storm and Wolverine in order to
form a team of characters that would
have had a better Dynamic together in a
realistic setting then Logan eventually
makes his way to the upper levels of the
X-Mansion where he sneaks about the
interior of the x-mension was actually
filmed inside of the famous Casa Loma
Castle mansion in Toronto Canada with
the exterior shots of the Mansion being
shot at the Parkwood estate in Ontario
which then leads Logan to meeting up
with Professor X at the end of his
physics class which Sean ashmore's
Iceman Alex Burton's pyro simela K's
Kitty pride and Katrina flores's Jubilee
in attendance the movie sequel would
find pyro recast with Aaron Stanford
Kitty Pride recast with a female
presenting Elliott page and Jubilee
recast with Kia Wong and during the
Montage that plays while Xavier shows
Logan around you can actually see the
first live action Colossus being played
by Donald McKinnon as Peter sketches his
surroundings in his Sketchbook this role
would be recast in X-Men 2 with Daniel
Cudmore who would stay on as Colossus
for X2 X-Men Last Stand and Days of
Future Past but anyways soon after this
we can see Mystique do her first full
transformation and to her blue scaly
form in order to achieve this look model
actress Rebecca Romaine would have to
sit through seven to eight hours of
having her makeup applied which meant
coming into the studio at about 1 to 3
A.M in the morning to get started which
is kind of nuts but considering that
they had to paint her entire body blue
while applying over 100 Prosthetics to
her body including two layers of contact
lenses that severely limited her vision
I definitely understand why it takes so
long but it was definitely worth it in
my opinion because mystique's makeup
looks fantastic in this movie especially
when compare to mystique's last
portrayal in 2019's X-Men dark Phoenix
which just looks like Jennifer Lawrence
at her local Comic-Con but anyways
during the scene where Jean Gray is
going over Wolverine's mutation and
adamantium skeleton you can really see
just how much Jean Gray's
characterization in the movies differs
from the comics this isn't major part to
a lot of Jean Gray's line from the movie
originally belonging to the X-Men beast
from an earlier version of the script
before cost cutting forced Beast roll to
be removed from the movie entirely along
with Nightcrawler and Pyro but of course
pyro was eventually reduced to a
background character but anyways moving
on as Magneto has his talk about fearing
god with a kidnap Senator Kelly he
mentions that he perceives God to be a
teacher and a bringer of light goodness
and understanding I thought that this
line was particularly interesting
because these are all qualities that his
former best friend Charles Xavier
possesses as a teacher in his school for
gifted youngsters which to me very much
hints at the great degree of respect
that Magneto has for Charles Xavier a
respect that Eric doesn't really vote
localized to anyone until after Xavier's
death and X-Men the Last Stand and then
when Magneto steps into his machine that
Taps into his biology and life force in
order to spread mutating radiation I
couldn't help but feel that Eric's
machine was essentially Magneto's
anti-cerebro earlier in the film we
learned from Professor X that him and
Magneto worked on Building cerebro
Together in order to locate other
mutants but while cerebro was made to
reach out to people Magneto's Evolution
machine was made to radically and
drastically change people so both of
their machines very much reflect their
respective characters and Emissions but
anyways after this we then see Jean Gray
unlocking quick flashes of memory from
the day all those war generals gathered
around to watch a hairy Canadian man get
baptized into adamantium fun fact Kevin
feige was actually supposed to be one of
the generals in this scene but
unfortunately his Cameo did not make the
final cut way before his days as the
head of the MCU Kevin feige's first
producer credit was as an associate
producer for this very movie so it's a
bummer for his cameo get deleted for
sure however Kevin feige would get his
chance to get an X-Men cameo in the
pages of X-Men 21 from 2021 but a cameo
we did get in this movie is of course
from none other than Stan the Man Lee as
we can see him as a hot dog vendor when
a mutated Senator Kelly arrives on the
beach but while Stan Lee is a highlight
of the scene I also found the symbolism
of this moment to be quite powerful
because much like Evolution caused fish
to walk on the shores of land billions
of years ago a newly evolved Senator
Kelly emerges onto the beach in the same
symbolic way Kevin feige would also
bring back this beach Evolution
symbolism with director Chloe Zhao at
the start of their evolution-centric
eternals film as the first deviant of
that movie symbolically emerges onto a
beach as well moving on when Storm's
group of X-Men go to pick Rogue up from
the train station Cyclops smiles back at
a little boy who Smiles at him this
moment wasn't planned at all but was
actually a genuine moment between actor
James Marsden and a massive fan of
Cyclops from the X-Men cartoon after
that moment was caught on camera the
director decided to keep it in the movie
and directed the boy's mother to give
Cyclops a dirty look but while we're on
the subject of Cyclops when Scott
accidentally blows the roof off the
train station notice how his eye beams
sort of Splash against the ceiling like
water the visual effects supervisor for
the movie Michael Fink leaned into the
idea of Cyclops concussive beams
possessing the concussive force of a
large body of water like they made sure
to not make cyclops's Powers feel like a
hot melting laser at all because that's
not how his power set works in the
comics but anyways fun fact about that
scene of Magneto ripping that train car
of people apart the Film Production
actually physically ripped a train par
full of people apart to achieve this
effect practically with most of the
reactions of the frightened people in
the car being 100 genuine and according
to Hugh Jackman immediately after they
yelled cut for that moment Sparks
started raining down from where the
train was cut in half and there was a
spirit of genuine Panic among all the
actors but luckily the production had
everything well under control so nobody
died died or caught fire that we know
about
just kidding nobody died but speaking of
Magneto they actually gave Sir Ian
McKellen a bodysuit to wear in order to
give Magneto a larger and more
intimidating physique but Magneto
doesn't even need to be swole when he's
got the power over magnetism which he
uses to spread Wolverine's claws apart
before shooting him across the train
those bendy Wolverine claws were
actually one of the 15 different sets of
Wolverine claws that they had for this
movie as different situations called for
different types of claws like when Logan
made the Casual oopsie of stabbing Rogue
through the chest they needed a
Different Cloth set for that but anyways
a little later when Magneto Toad and
Sabertooth have a Face-Off with the cops
we see Magneto threatened to slowly put
a metal bullet through a police
officer's forehead a moment I found
reminiscence to Michael fassbender's
magnetos slowly putting a coin through
Kevin Bacon's forehead in first class so
I feel like this moment inspired that
Moment In First Class later on but
anyways as the X-Men head off to rescue
Rogue in the xjet Cyclops asked
Wolverine if he would prefer if they all
wore yellow spandex which was of course
a light joke after the original X-Men
comic designs from the comics as well as
the popular animated series at the time
and although it would have been super
dope to see the X-Men in their comic
book accurate costumes the year 2000 was
a much different time for comic book
movies and the producers of X-Men 2000
knew that 20th Century Fox as a whole
viewed the entire production of X-Men
2000 as a bit of a risk considering that
comic book movies were starting to
become less popular in the public eye
following flops like spawn Ninja Turtles
3 steel and Batman and Robin people just
figured that comic book movies are for
little kids who didn't mind extremely
high levels of corniness and bad writing
so the producers of X-Men 2000 knew that
they had to make sure to write a mature
and relatable story set in a similar
looking world to the wand right outside
their windows so they made sure that
their costumes wouldn't make them stand
out like they were costumed wrestlers
fighting crime but as a believable
Strike Team of elite superhumans working
in unison but while we're on the subject
of the suits y'all want to hear
something hilarious when the X-Men first
arrived at the base of the Statue of
Liberty and storm Cyclops Gene and
Wolverine have to hop over this barrier
none of the actors could physically get
over the barrier because their suits
were so damn tight like they were all
struggling to move and evens kind of
struggling to breathe but this was also
actually the moment a lot of the crew on
set got to see all four of them in
costume for the first time so as soon as
the Director yells cut everyone screamed
and clapped at the sight of the X-Men in
live action but anyways after Logan
splits off from the rest of the group
and when they arrive at the Statue of
Liberty Museum I love how they have the
fake Mystique Wolverine appear from the
left of the frame behind the pillar
after Logan clearly goes off to the
right of The Fray giving the audience a
clue that this wasn't the real Logan
approaching before she even popped her
fake claws out fake claws that
apparently are still extremely sharp
despite not being adamantium themselves
but speaking of that I find it really
interesting how they had Mystique scream
out in her own voice when Wolverine cut
out her fake flesh claws because it kind
of implies that there is a degree of
concentration needed for mystique to
duplicate the voices of others and also
Mystique didn't originally have that
action sequence with her and Logan and
for in the movie however after seeing
how great Mystique looked in action on
set the production felt compelled to let
this blueberry badass battle the
bearded-bladed Berserker and while toad
faces off against Jean Gray a little
later on before giving her his surprise
slime he does a little Jester's dance as
a nod to the court gesture-like
personality that toad originally had in
the comics which I thought was a little
nice touch and later after storm tells
Magneto about the fate of a very bloated
Senator Kelly mekito asked storm if
she's sure she saw what she saw and you
know what that's actually a really great
Point all storm really saw was Senator
Kelly turned into water but technically
that doesn't mean that Senator Kelly was
necessarily dead but if turning into a
water puddle was just his new weird
mutation y'all remember that TV show The
Secret World of Alex Mack from the 90s
about that little white girl that could
make herself into a liquid puddle for
all storm new Kelly could be a mutant
puddled Hydro man or something The
Secret World of Kelly Mack wait The
Secret World of of Robert Kelly
Wait no that's R Kelly anyway which
is possibly why Magneto was unfazed by
Storm's words of warning I also find it
quite ironic how Magneto is completely
blind to his fears having caused him to
become the very monster that he feared
the most by putting an innocent child in
captivity and causing them to suffer for
the good of a group of humans who
believe themselves to be superior Eric's
own crew actions with the Brotherhood of
mutants mirror the Nazis as the Nazis
too believed that their unethical
Behavior was a Justified means to an end
but anyways after the X-Men saved the
day we of course get our t's for the
sequel of the movie when Xavier shows
Logan some imagery of alkali Lake the
location of Striker's Weapon X military
complex well Wolverine first got his
claws in the future death site for one
gene gray who of course dies at the end
of X2 before being reborn as the Phoenix
for X-Men the Last Stand finally as
Xavier and Magneto play chess together
at the end of the film Magneto
sacrificing all of his Pawn pieces to
try to win the game is deeply reflective
of his belief that absolutely anyone is
Expendable to him in his war against
humanity and this is of course before he
tips his own King piece over to
symbolically concede defeat against
Xavier for winning their first battle in
what would eventually become a Trilogy
of a war for the fate of unkind but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this breakdown of X-Men 2000 I
cannot wait to break down even more
Marvel movies for you guys because like
we got a really great Marvel breakdown
series coming up with the next movie
being blade I hope you don't like
vampires because they're all about to
die
follow me at mastertonment on Twitter
Instagram or wherever I am on the social
medias but most importantly do not
forget to subscribe to heavy spoilers
right now because we got some dope stuff
for you that you don't want to miss
anyways thanks again for watching this
video I love you guys so so so much and
I can't wait to break down more cool
Marvel stuff for you in the future stay
tuned I'll see you guys soon goodbye